something new today how's that uh
as chair of division two of the house
finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic and
in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this public meeting is pertaining to
shoot hb
sorry hb 594 fn
and hb 613
fnl if there is time following these
two issues we will be looking at
hb1 and hb2
please note that there is no fiscal
location for members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access
to contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate
in this meeting by the zoom platform or
by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules
and rsa 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing this
meeting
should email lba underscore
fiscal at leg.state.nh dot us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote let's
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required under
the right to know law representative
lynn
if you would um take
attendance please yes uh thank you madam
chair
uh representative porter i'm here in my
home in hillsborough
i'm alone in the room but my husband and
cats are in the house
thank you representative i'm home in
barrington
uh by myself in this room my wife is in
the house somewhere
represent thank you representative heath
good morning mary heath here in
manchester
um in my home and my husband is um just
leaving so i'll be home alone shortly
thank you i'm bob lynn i'm uh here alone
at my
uh home and win i'm sorry i'm here in
the room alone in my home and window my
wife is elsewhere in the house
um representative murray good morning
kate murray here in newcastle the dog's
here
david is in the next room right now um
he'll be heading down
outside later thank you representative
petrie
right resident petrie is uh here in
concord in the uh
finance offices uh the little auntie
room off of the break room
all right thank you and representative
umber
uh yes i'm in my home in kearsarge and
my husband is in the house
thank you thank you very much uh
representative lynn um
i do want to mention that uh at one
o'clock
today we're having our uh
public hearing on hb1 and hb2
and i'm sure like all of you
um we have received probably
a hundred emails with
um with testimony attached to it
and so i have
absolutely no idea how long this
public hearing is going to last this
afternoon
the other thing that i wanted to
point out is that
there are several people
that don't realize
that the finance committee
works differently than uh
the other committees in that the lba
is the office that
takes care of the things that we do and
so
if anyone you talk to
is having trouble or whatever on the
general court website they have
a list of all of the committee meetings
that are going on that day
and you can click on finance 2 and the
zoom connection will come up
so it's um i
probably had i don't know four or five
different people
saying i can't get in i can't get in i
can't do this so
um just make sure that um
people that you're talking to are
are aware that this is how you get to
uh to finance
and for our meetings tomorrow and
thursday that will be the
access point for those meetings
so there we have it and i just wanted to
just wanted to make sure that uh
everybody
understands um you know
what what's happening here so our first
the first bill that we're going to
look at this morning is um
excuse me five
597 594
excuse me uh an act relative
to the school building aid program
uh mickey is there anyone
in the um
participants area that
has their hand raised i've got um
representative cahill who's a co-sponsor
here
and he's been brought in to speak have
um
uh amy clark from the department of
education i'll bring her in
um and i also have representative hill
and
uh looks like former representative dan
mcguire is here too with their hands
raised i'm not sure if they are here to
speak on
594 613 but it's up to you if you want
to bring everybody in now
i know that uh uh
dan mcguire i believe wants to speak on
both of them
okay so if you could um bring
him up i i'm not positive but i think
if i remember the email i got a while
ago that's
uh that's what he um publishing
representative hill in as well
and then uh just so he's prepared when
we get to whenever he wants to
participate okay that'll be fine that'll
be fine
okay uh representative cahill would you
like to
uh to start with um
the bill yes thank you very much matt
and chair members of the committee out
i'll just uh for the benefit of the
public i'll just briefly read the uh
the uh written testimony i gave i sent
you last night and
then talk about a few of the doc
supporting documents
so hb 594 as passed by the education
committee would begin to address the
needs of schools on the waiting lists
and implement a 10-year plan to enable
better management
for the state and school districts we
know the need for improvements will be
ongoing much like the other sba the
state bridge aid
which has a waiting list of over 250 red
list municipal bridges
we cannot allow our school buildings to
decline or to place the entire cost of
renovations
on property taxpayers a 10-year plan is
just a plan unless it is funded in the
budget every year
the state with a few exceptions has not
contributed to the cost of school
district projects
since 2010 and many communities such as
mine were denied even the ability to
apply for school building aid
this was not because the projects were
unnecessary for wants rather than needs
but because the legislature would not
fund the program
when i spoke with governor sununu last
week he said he wished the legislature
would restore
funding that he had to work around it
when allocating
funds for security infrastructure in the
wake of the school shootings
i want you to pass hb 594-f
but also want you to re to consider what
was removed the retroactive funding
and the return to annual bond payments
let's look at the project
recently approved by the voters in
allenstown
if you don't pass this bill the this
thirty two and
thirty two and a half million dollar
project will be added to the list of
those without state funding
if you pass the bill using the 80 20
payment method
15.6 million for this single project
would use half of the available
32 million that's 50 million in the bill
minus the debt the tail so what then for
the schools ranked a little lower
a little further down the list how many
of these will be able to wait
2 4 or 10 years to rise to the top
among the documents i'm submitting for
your consideration and the record is a
summary of the bond
for the new market project this
illustrates two points
one we're paying 25 million in interest
on the 30
39 million dollar project over 29 years
two we're paying an additional three
dollars and fifteen cents per thousand
until 2046 this is uh on our property
taxes this would perhaps be a dollar
less
if we had our 30 percent uh grant paid
annually
so while there would have been savings
over using the eighty twenty method
receiving a portion of
over the life of the bond is preferable
to no state funding
i ask you to consider doing something
retroactively perhaps fifty percent
of what the grants would have been for
the affected communities
this could be spread over a number of
years as i would not want to delay work
on the pending projects however
i feel it is wrong to punish those whose
projects were the victims of bad timing
please also redirect the 30 million in
the governor's proposed
school infrastructure fund to the school
building aid program
which has served us well for decades
so again the let me talking about the
we have a long waiting list of schools
uh schools that couldn't even apply
schools that were
schools that were done during the
moratorium and i'm looking at the uh
the document that miss clark sent i
asked
her to send a list of other projects in
chronological order
and i she noted that these are these are
not
approved or it's an incomplete list
this is a result of a survey was we
don't really track buildings this is
this is what the schools have told us
but i note that one is absent i think
the first
victim of the moratorium was the
stephens high school in claremont that
missed the vote
missed the margin by one vote someone
stayed home to watch dancing with the
stars instead of casting a ballot
but that was a project i think it was 25
million and then
they they couldn't get the vote they
didn't win so a couple of years later
they came back with a much smaller
project
but again they had to pay the entire
cost so
let's list projects let's say from salem
to
we have nashua we have the mascoma
regional school
we have windham projects in hampton
all over the state and so this is not
just about
my community this is about your
communities and this is about
education something that's important to
the young families we hope to move to
new hampshire
and the businesses that would employ
them if they had the workforce
we can't just continue continue to
attract uh
seniors who made their money elsewhere
and not want to not want to buy a house
and not not bring kids we do need the
future workforce
the current and future workforce also i
sent the list of
that the education department has
submitted to the school building
authority there are 12 schools
12 schools on the list and then
supporting documents uh behind that and
then some of these have
uh structural integrity issues fire and
safety
uh plumbing all all sorts of problems
it's not just uh the wind that they like
a new building because the old ones
getting tired
it's structural and safety issues it's
overcrowding
looking again at that list of projects
some of them i i think probably wouldn't
really shouldn't get building aid
i think if you're if you're making
energy improvements the cost savings are
enough of an incentive
and i know that some some schools are
now doing the uh
power sharing so that they're able to
have uh their
release the the solar units or whatever
it is that
lowers their energy costs and uh you
know they can't get the municipalities
can't get the benefit that all the
benefits so
another entity third party comes in and
we still got the cheaper energy
and it's it's saving us money and i
think you know also the program needs to
be tweaked and that we shouldn't be
paying for
a new gym floor or perhaps even a new
furnace
those are maintenance items and the
towns should be putting something aside
in the budget every year
because it you know a a roof a boiler
they have a lifespan and over time
you could put something aside but you
know renovations
we needed renovations i sent you this
morning i sent you
uh the testimonial i offered to the to
the education committee which included
the
before and after pictures uh newmarket
the high school you know it was first
built in 1925
and it's a beautiful building but you
know we've had to add to it kabbalah
over the decades and it came to the
point where something else had to be
done
even the elementary school which was
built in the 90s
all of a sudden we had a boom we were
using modular classrooms
for about 30 years and i know there are
modular classrooms in many communities
across the state
that's not how education should be done
uh that's not
until not a long-term solution so again
i want you to pass the bill but i want
you to consider the amendments that
you'll be offered when you're in that
work session
amendments that would bring back uh the
retroactive funding
and maybe reconsider the 80 20. uh that
may work
that may work fine and in some cases but
uh
we won't be able to do very very many of
the projects if we if we're putting
80 up front for all of them
bond rates are very low right now this
is the time to do it
i realized that we got into trouble with
uh bonding years ago
and so many high schools were done all
at once and so
uh and you know of course if we hadn't
done them then they would be costing
even more now
i've been inside some of those schools
and they you know they have
stadiums they have uh auditoriums that
rival the wang center so i we should
also look at what
what defines a school i know defining an
education has been challenging but what
does
what's a school building and should we
pay for all the extras
if a community has the resources and is
willing to do
to uh spend the money for the bells and
whistles then perhaps they should do
that
and we should we should be finding
schools that meet the needs of our
community
and i'll gladly take any questions you
have
uh does anyone have any questions that
they would like to ask
representative heath um thank you
madam chair um thank you for your
testimony michael
so you're asking a couple of things for
us from us this morning um
you're asking us to support
house bill 594 as presented
and you're also asking us to consider
an amendment um that actually
will be coming forward in the work
session
and do you know the amount
of funding that would be
what what you are looking for
in the reimbursement for projects that
have been completed
prior to the moratorium
being lifted do you have a an amount
that you are looking for um
yes we need to find in the budget thank
you
thank you representative heath yes uh
according to the document that ms clark
provided
uh the building aid that the the towns
you know the town spent
the projects cost 537 million 174
495 dollars uh the
state the state building aid that would
have been provided
would be 186 million 141
161 dollars give us 50 cents on the
dollar
do something
and if you want you know i don't i know
you can't just write a check today
but you know spread it out warlocks
while some of our taxpayers
that are helping to pay this are still
up above ground and breathing
uh let's help them a little bit i mean
the money that you give to us we could
put
we could lower our tax rates we could
again be putting money aside for some of
those other education things down the
road
and i think it just makes it's the right
thing to do rather than just walk away
and say
well you're out of luck all these
communities that we all
live in and hope to have children
educated
in uh madam chair may i inquire further
please
uh yes you may um now
um this bill would restore funding
to the 50 million level dollar level
um but my question to you
is i completely think the 10 year plan
is an excellent idea however i also
understand that number one our budget
we're trying to figure it out and the
amount that you're looking for
um may not be realistic
but in a 10-year plan
we can't go back to building aid as it
used to because you know we're still
paying off the tail
and it it just ended up a serious
problem and
that's back in 2000 2010 that's why we
had ended i think was actually 2008 i'm
not sure the date
um we actually had to bond the payment
for building aid because there just
wasn't enough money to
to balance the budget now in the 10-year
plan are we going to look
at a different way to approve
building projects much like what cte
does
where they put school districts in a
queue and then when that
time period comes up then in fact a a
project can either be uh approved at the
local level or the but the school
district
knows when their turn is coming up um
is that what you're looking for i don't
know that's why i'm asking
uh thank you representative um yeah i
i think the the cte is a good is a good
model and i'm glad you brought that up
because a few of the
a few of the communities that did build
salem and dover
uh had the benefit of having ctes which
also had the benefit of federal money
and wouldn't that be nice um
the other the other thing with the list
is that you know we have a list of
projects and
we don't know someone might come in next
year and say well we've been holding off
we've been holding off we couldn't do it
and now our school is is really worse
than the top three
uh so i i think it might be good to have
a plan i'm hoping there would be more
enough funding so that we could do not
just one school
every every uh 20 years or every you
know but with some frequency in a group
of schools
this is why i think we have to have we
just have to know that this money has to
be there
and we can't be taking it out with a
clever use of a notwithstanding
when you write the budget we the money
has to be there
it has to come from somewhere so because
right now the other document i sent you
is the summary
of the new market bond payment if you
look at that
you know we're looking at uh
61 million 368 000
69 50 69.6 and 53 cents
that we're paying for this the whole
thing because the state reneged
so i'm sympathetic to the bond question
i know on finance you
you guys are the experts and uh figure
all the numbers i don't know what it
would have been
you know i i know it would have been
less if we if you had
if he paid us the 30 percent we would do
if you gave us 80
up front then we you know that would
have been great but you have to do
something we can't just continue
like this thank you michael
thank you are there um further questions
for uh representative cahill
um i'd like to just make a statement if
i could
uh the reason that we changed to the 80
20 methodology
was because bond issue after bond issue
after bond issue around the state was
failing
and so the legislature believed
that if we were able to provide the 80
up front with the 20 at the end
that we would see more bond
issues passing now i realize
uh i believe the last
in the last budget cycle we were
fortunate that
our economy was such that we had
ex i don't want to call it extra money
but we had
money available to do some of the things
that uh we we wanted to do and we want
to do
every year i mean or every two years i'm
i i am also i think dismayed
about the um the fact that we have not
been able to uh
to support the building aid program
but when you look at the budget and the
money that's available
you have to make decisions and
unfortunately
i think that is the position that we are
in this cycle
um i
i am a little concerned or i i don't
i won't argue that 50 million probably
is
is a relatively good figure but
we're struggling right now to fill
an 18 million dollar gap in
the education trust fund
the other issue that i have
is that in the last biennium
building aid went into the education
trust fund
and your bill as it stands right now
moves it out of the education trust fund
and back into the general fund
uh where it was before
and um so i have i have some
real concerns about that um
i think that what we have seen over the
last
four years anyhow is that
um the education trust fund has been
uh relatively healthy
whereas the general
fund has had some significant
uh significant problems and
this year in particular uh the
general fund has a huge problem
and um so i just wanted to
to make that information available to
um the committee as well as anybody that
that might be listening
senator keith oh madam chad thank you
thank you so much for bringing that up
um that was an
issue that um we really worked hard on
in the last biennium and we thought that
it would give building aid actually more
protection
and then relieve the stress on the
general fund
so um i would hope that we would in fact
leave the building aid within the
context of
the education trust i thank you for that
okay you're welcome
represent yep
go ahead represent caleb yes thank you
madam chair i
i defer to your to your experience and
wisdom on these matters of
which which kettle the money should come
in and out of
um and i do appreciate you know the
circumstances we find ourselves and i
you know however i also know that you
know um
you know when we think about you know
the young families that we want to have
come and stay in new hampshire that you
know if they had to have 80
down in order to buy a home home
ownership would be nowhere
and uh so while i don't like debt i
don't like paying interest
if it's just something that we had to
accept and plan for
like the alternative is not fixing our
schools not fixing our bridges
and so that's what unless we like it but
i do thank you and i trust the committee
will do
its best to uh honor our commitments
thank you very again
okay thank you um for the
people please remember to raise your
hand
if you want to speak and i
see that representative hill has his
hand raised
yes manager um i'll i'll try to be brief
here uh this is a big topic and
and i think it's maybe the reason that
uh this bill cries out for being
retained um i am the
chair of the aforementioned school
building authority
um have been for i think i'm on my
second or third year now um this
is a project that um that needs reform
and i'll try to give you a couple of
small pieces for the committee to
consider
the the 12 projects that the sponsor
mentioned earlier i think i
if i highlight some of these these
you'll see
some of the difficulties that we have
with with school building aid
one of the major problems that i see is
that these projects
can be applied for in june or july
actually
and it's possible that they have never
been approved by the local districts
the local voters so you know amy clark
at doe the school building authority the
board of ed
and now you all have to put
time effort and energy into evaluating
projects
that the voters may not even want
in fact one sunapee project this year
just this last week was voted down by
the voters um
so all of amy's work um to evaluate that
project
is is pretty much wasted
and and that you know cheap yankee here
i i'm not happy about wasting time and
money
um but uh but then we get into
so that's a big problem and and i think
right now we have
six and possibly seven of the
of the 12 projects that are in that
category have
no voter approval um
there's another three or four here
that are going before the voters and
have no contingency built in for
um for building aid so
the assumption is if it passes in that
town meeting then they will be building
it regardless of
building aid we have the three
major projects have already been
approved by the voters
and have said that they are building it
with or without building aid i have a
hard time
thinking about the poor voters of uh i
don't know lisbon or
berlin or somewhere like that paying for
a project
in salem when the salem
or nashua voters have said we're going
to build this without
with or without building aid so i have a
hard time having
others chip in for a project like that
um then we get into
the project that was rated the first on
the list
which happens to be my district uh
believe it or not
um but it is um it was built on a faulty
demographic study so the project itself
when it came to amy clark
um was the project was
an expansion of an elementary school
that the demographic study
pointed out to increased demographics
student demographics they've since been
unable to
replicate that demographic study and
they've shown decreased
populations well here we go again amy is
is evaluating a project that um
that was um faulty um approved or
applied for in the first place so
i think i'll leave it there there's a
number of private problems with this
project with this
this process um not the least of which
is the
is the timeline um and that gets to that
voter approval or not
um i think uh i think a few of us could
sit down for a month and
and come up with a better solution than
what we have here just um
increasing the amount of money going to
building aid
if i had my druthers and i don't in the
as the chair of the school billing
authority
i have no ability to say this is not a
good project for the
for the taxpayers and voters of new
hampshire i have
only the ability to rank the projects
um that's that's kind of
a tough position to be in when we have a
an authority that is
that is populated with the state fire
marshal
the state treasurer the commissioner of
education
um another person in finance who happens
to be me
and another a building authority um
that all of us are quote unquote experts
in our field
but all we have the ability to do is
check
amy clark's math um on the matrix of
of ranking these uh projects with
available points
um it's the 10-year plan is a great idea
i'll i'll absolutely go for that um
i think that's been a suggestion right
from the get-go
but uh the idea of increasing the
building aid um
just because of the request to do
something
um that's not the right way to go as far
as
as far as i go and i'll leave it there
thank you
uh thank you representative hill uh
honorable mr mcguire you have
you have uh a comment or a question
well i just wanted to give sort of
testimony on this bill
um all right
go ahead i read the hand there um
so first of all thank you madam chair
thank you for welcoming me back
to division two uh which was my original
committee
uh when i was in the legislature ten
years ago and before i got sucked
into the bottomless poll of division
three
um so today i'm
i'm a member of the board of granite
state taxpayers so what i'm talking
about is
is you know endorsed or on behalf of
granite state taxpayers
and um i agree with representative
cahill
that our demographics is is definitely
an
issue new hampshire depending on how you
measure
is either the second oldest or perhaps
the sixth oldest state in the country
and but i i question whether
building schools is the best way to
solve that problem
um just in general uh
he told a story about
there was a district that wanted to
build a 25 million dollar school
it wasn't approved and later the voters
approved
a lesser project now it seems to us
or to me that this is entirely
appropriate
because when you subsidize something
like this
this particular area subsidizes schools
you end up with more of it that's simple
economics
so um and this is a problem with
government financing in general when one
level of government
hands a lower level of government money
um that government that lower level will
spend
whatever it is that they can afford to
spend on that
item plus all the stuff that they got
handed
so so the net result of this project
program
is that that more
uh schools will be built then
then it would happen otherwise then
would happen
if the same entity that was making the
decision to build schools
was the one paying for it um
and that's not to say that you couldn't
still i mean if you have 50 million
dollars burning a hole in your pocket
you can't
help out towns right as a really trivial
way to help out towns is simply to lower
the statewide property tax by 50 million
dollars
if you wanted to be slightly more
sophisticated uh and do it by student
you could help out towns by uh raising
the
the um adequate education age
five percent and that would be another
way to spend 50 million dollars on
education but it would be done without
the negative consequences of
overbuilding
right and and you know i realized that
probably
people who build large commercial
structures
would not like that right they want to
build stuff
but otherwise it would be roughly the
equivalent
and you would get schools right sized
for their purpose
thank you manager thank you uh
representative porter
you have a question i do i
thank you madam chair and i'm trying to
kind of get my head around this
um it was mentioned that there were
communities that were passing
bonds with or putting a project up with
or without
state funding and it seemed to me the
implication was
uh the state funding was
superfluous and it didn't matter
that the state should not be funding
projects that
would be funded anyway by the community
and i'm
i'm wondering if rather we should be
looking at it
is this funding has been so sporadic
unreliable and meager in the last years
that communities who know they need to
repair their school or upgrade their
school or
build a new one because the one they
have is falling down are willing to take
realize their responsibility to take it
on with or without state funding
um so i'm i'm just throwing that out
there as a
maybe you can explain it to me why that
would be a negative
for giving um building aid to a
community if they're willing to build
without
without it does that make any sense did
i make any sense with that
uh yes you made sense thank you thank
you
did i ask a question no i'm sorry
um representative heath i understand you
have a proposed amendment to this bill
and i think everyone received it i hope
you did
um would you like to
um say something about this i i do
um the purpose of the amendment
is to address the concerns that
representative cahill brought
up for reconsideration toward those
projects
um to some extent that have not been
funded
and take that under consideration
okay
what you're okay let me make sure i'm
i'm understanding what you're saying
um basically
in paragraph in paragraph three
which is the new paragraph yes this is
the um that's saying that
projects between july 13th
and 2020 yes maybe
may be considered yes okay
and you are looking at a
20 percent
award if that's the right yes right term
for those
um for those back projects
madam chair i have a question
raise your hand please
thank you sorry about that
um i do not have a copy of this
amendment
um when was it sent and was it sent
prior to me being
put on the committee bob doesn't either
it looks like
i will send the um
amendment to the entire committee now
and also post it online but i can also
share a screen if that's useful to
at least walk through the amendment
michael that would be very helpful
yeah it's it's very hard with amendments
right now because
you know it
um we don't know whether the person is
going to offer them or not
and and so we we
uh i have tried to make sure that
i got these out to everybody but maybe i
didn't
okay so section three
section three is up there uh basically
the
um if i understood correctly
um four
you're also talking about a new
paragraph on the ten-year plan
yes which is two
so let's go to two first
and then we'll go to three so
the importance of the um ten-year plan
i think is critical and and i know that
amy is out here
and i'd like her to perhaps even um give
some feedback to that
but i just think by having a plan it
puts us
um in a mode that we have a better
handle on the needs that are out there
and um the things that we need to have
in place to make this
work um because of the fact we know we
cannot go back to the system
the way it was previously so i think if
we put together a 10-year plan
then we're going to have be able to plan
we can budget and we have order in terms
of where we're going with building aid
across the state of new hampshire
mary mary amy
would you like to comment on the concept
of a 10 year plan
i'm sure for the record amy clark with
the department of education school
safety and facility management um yeah i
think
the feedback from schools are that
they can't move forward with building a
school is not something you do over a
weekend
it's not even something you do in a
year's time it typically takes
two to five years to plan for a large
school construction project
but the uncertainty of building aid puts
schools um especially poorer schools at
a disadvantage because they have to
spend
maybe in the realm of a hundred thousand
dollars or so
for planning for construction really
allows the state
to um start planning its resources a
little bit better instead of just saying
oh here's some money
uh who's up for it and then you get the
schools that are building anyway
um to representative hill's point
of some schools are moving forward with
construction anyhow
that's not the case with all schools on
that list some schools
um that were ranked uh did not even vote
on building aid because
uh their projects because they were
uncertain about building aid where a
10-year plan
really gives everybody an idea of when
they're up next
um should funding be available
madam clear if i may yes please go ahead
um i am a former oh i used to work at
the department of ed
and i also was an assistant
superintendent and passing a bond
is extraordinarily hard and i referred
to the cte
process they have in our capital budget
and how well it works
because it gives you that time period
when you know that your district will be
coming up
for an award that you have time to work
with your community
you have time to do the work you need to
work um do
in order to get it funded um it's not an
easy task
and for many of us who have worked in
districts we know
that to get any kind of a bond passed it
can take up to
two or three years um coming before the
budget of
the um town committees
to get those plans in fact approved
so the 10-year plan i think is a logical
sequence and it puts in place a
structure within which
we in the budget committee can work and
those folks at the district level can
work as well it just it provides order
in a structure
that um will keep us from falling into
that
uh unfortunate situation of having a
tail that's
been driving us for the last few years
thank you
okay does is there anyone else that
would like to comment
on the concept of the
10-year plan
uh let me say
that i attended
i don't know some cte committee
that i'm on for the state and um
they are very concerned about the
rotation
and and what's going on in that arena so
even though they have a plan um one of
the problems that they've had
is that um the school districts
that are up for the cte money
are not approving the projects so it
it doesn't matter whether there's a plan
or there's not
it's uh unfortunately sometimes
um voters are very strange i'll put it
that way
so okay representative lynn you have a
question
yes thank you madam chair and i i really
i guess i i
direct this to whoever sort of has
knowledge of the of the operation of the
plan because
because candidly i'm i'm just i'm i'm
ignorant and i want to i want to
learn what this is about but here's i i
am i understanding that the way the
proposed 10-year plan would work would
be the
department of education would sort of
survey the state
and say okay here are and i'm just using
this to pick this number out of the air
but say okay
here are 10 school districts
in which new building
of of one kind or another is uh
is appropriate and
um we're going to rank the order in
which we the department of education
thinks that these should be
approved um is is that
is that kind of the idea because i i
guess
one of the things i'm having trouble
understanding is how that
and it sort of goes along with what
representative umberger was just saying
about the cte
program is how does if that's what the
the idea of what the state department of
education
is supposed to do if that's the idea
i kind of wonder how that if that
doesn't
interfere in some sense with local with
local control
in the sense that suppose that
a district where the where the state
department of education might think that
it's
it's high on its list of uh
uh a district where where approval
should be given
but there's a great debate within the
town about whether this should be done
or not
um is the
you know is the department of education
placing it on the list kind of
place putting a hand on the scale there
um
to tip the vote one way or the other
and and is that a good idea i guess
that's my that's really my
uh my question in the end
okay um
amy do you want to uh answer that
or is there somebody else here
i can i can this is uh representative
hill
okay so um i think representative lynn
has an excellent point and and um
does point out one of the problems
with the idea of a 10-year plan and i
have seen it in action
there is there is an effect of putting
your thumb
on the scale in the current system as
well
i have seen districts
um they came on this matrix
and the and the ranking um near the top
of the list
that it was put to the voters um
to the effect see uh the state thinks
that this is a good project
and and are willing to pay for it so
therefore
you should vote for it um because the
state
thinks it's a good project so that
that is something to be aware of um
you know it also is difficult and i
agree with uh
chairman umberger um uh tremendously
here because
um bricks and mortar are a hard thing to
uh to push through
in in good times and yet we're in we're
in a position here now
where we've had buildings school
buildings be empty for
a year and people aren't sure whether
um their their children will be back in
their schools in their
in their regular form um they're also
uh see the the statement from the
commissioner of education that uh
that says for schools to prepare for a
future significant declines
in population so you can see that
they're hesitant to
um to outlay for 20 a building that's
going to have to be there for 20 years
because there is an
rsa a piece in the rsa that says
if this building isn't used by the end
of the
uh the duration of this that that
billing aid could be returned or have to
be returned
i don't know if that's ever taken place
but um
but certainly it's an overhanging issue
so all of those reasons i agree
wholeheartedly with representative lin
that it's a question that needs to be
answered
uh representative heath you have a
question i do i just kind of
a follow-up um i um
fully understand the need
for a plan um and i i also want to add
that it doesn't put the thumb
on the scale of a school district simply
because a district would then
be eligible for a building project but
it allows them
to do some planning if in need that's
something in
their long-term plan there's no
requirement that they have to do this
and there are school districts yes i
completely agree
enrollment numbers across the state are
declining
but we do have districts that are
growing in fact
wyndham for example is exploding bedford
has seen
extraordinary growth um the need
for building aid remains i think we
recognize that the pandemic is
hopefully moving to a conclusion our
students will be returning to school
and there there continues to be needs um
that buildings have
in order to move forward so i i
just want to protest a little bit the
fact that the thumb on the scale
because it does not try in any way
to usurp local control it simply is
adding
a plus to what a school district can put
into their plans that they are building
thank you very much madam chair and i
see that representative cahill has a
question as well
right um representative hill you had
some comments that you wanted to make or
questions
then i will go to representative cahill
no i'm sorry i just didn't drop my hand
i apologize
no problem representative cahill thanks
very much uh
and chair uh to our representative
representative hill's uh statement i i
recall like
i i think of my first term that
lancaster's turn
came up for cte at a renovation
and they turned it down so it's not
you know the voters still had the final
word and uh
i also want to add that if not for the
renovation that we did here in newmarket
i don't think we'd have been able to
have
uh all our students in the elementary
school
within allowing for the social
distancing that we did that
and our junior high and senior you know
junior senior high school
was operational uh nearly all the time
except for a couple of exposure
incidents
because we expanded both buildings and
if we weren't able to do that
it would be a different situation thank
you
thank you uh representative heath would
you like to go on to paragraph three
please
yes so in paragraph
three what this does is it opens up an
opportunity if funds allow
to reimburse at the rate of 20 percent
those school districts who have indeed
gone forward with local building
projects
during the period of the moratorium
and i think it's something that if
indeed
funds became available that this would
be something
to try and at least take a step forward
to make some of these districts
partially whole in terms of what has
been asked
for them and and i think that
representative cahill
has certainly spoke in depth at what
the town of newmarket has experienced
they had a need they had to go forward
and there are many school districts that
won't meet our state minimum standards
unless they go forward with a building i
know that there
when i worked as deputy commissioner we
had a number of local school districts
that because of the condition of their
buildings
that they could not get approval and
they were
safety hazards um so something had to be
done
so i think based on the years
that we've seen come before us that the
state
does have some um
potential obligation to try and
and do something if it would become
possible
but you know i have to say um that
indeed
i believe that the most important thing
is to
re-establish full funding in each year
of the biennium
for building aid and secondly
the 10-year plan or a plan to refigure
and that could that will be people
coming together
to figure out what the plan is going to
be under the wise
um leadership of amy
so i mean these are all things that are
critically important to our state
and schools are not going to go away
we're going to continue
to have needs across our state schools
are a fundamental core
of our cities and towns and they will
continue to be
thank you madam chair okay
uh is there anyone else that has any
comments or questions
uh yes amy if i may
i just want to make um too important to
what i think are important points
is um keep in mind i oftentimes hear
about space and cost and
declining enrollment and all of that
thing keep in mind that the current law
already caps the square footage per
student
and it cos it caps the cost
um to of construction so there are
lots of large spaces that some local
school districts build
but if you look at the cap of square
footage per student
it is um typically smaller than what
schools are
uh proposing so um and then so that's
one point
and then the other point is really that
special education space
um is much different
i will say that there is potentially
like when you go in
and look at schools there might be some
spaces that used to be empty
but um special education spaces are
somewhat significant in school so
um those would be the only two points i
wanted to make sure that were
available thank you
muted madam chair well i know that's
because i was thinking in my thoughts i
i have i have two thoughts here okay
um my first
thought is
on the 10-year plan
okay uh
i've heard the arguments on both sides
of it
but there's in my opinion
oops nothing wrong with planning
i'm not sure that um
i i'm not i agree that if you're
building a brand new project that's
going to take you five years to
to get it together but i'm not sure
how good school boards are
at planning for the long term i
i i know that
all of us um you know have
issues with long-term planning but
i am personally not opposed
to the the concept of the 10-year plan
i think we have a reality check
in regards to any funding
for this program for this year this
biennium
and so
the question that i have
is if people agree
does it make sense to change
594 to only include
the incorporation of a 10-year plan
and you know and eliminate all the
others
or does it make sense would you prefer
to retain the entire bill to
uh try to work on um
you know what what we can do about
school building eight
i don't expect you know mary
you you had you had that money tree
growing out there in your backyard okay
so those are
those are my thoughts okay and i would
um
i would just like to to hear from people
about
you know which is which is the best
because
i i i i know all of us know
that we cannot fund this at this time
representative heath um thank you ma'am
cheer and thank you for your comments
i i would not have a problem at all with
it being retained
i know that in the last biennium
we worked together and there are a lot
of these kinds of bills that we were
able to get
into the um budget and that would be
my preference because i think we'd have
to go there eventually anyway
so um if we were to retain it i would
not have a problem with it
um i also don't want
the bill um to
be itled
if in fact the um amendment were not
accepted
and just to put out there i also have a
second amendment
that mickey had worked on that took out
the um the 20 uh
payment back to schools so that would be
something that certainly i would
entertain too
but i number one i'd be happy to have
the amendment
included as written um with the
um refund the funding opportunities back
to
um completed projects
but if that becomes a too serious a
liability
then i i would re withdraw that section
but i do
think the consideration of full
funding for building aid and the 10-year
plan
are two critical elements in long-term
for building aid
um and if we could do something with
that
i would be most pleased
if i may just to clarify the 10-year
plan is already in
house bill 594 as amended and passed
by education yeah so that's already in
the bill the only change in the
amendment that we walked through was
section three
and you are on mute representative
umberger
representative yes is that a motion to
retain
i would move to retain um house bill
594 yes
okay do i have a second and then we'll
have discussion
i'll second that uh representative petry
yes okay thank you
i had my hand up but it's not to do with
i obviously can't vote
on this but i had my hand up to clarify
one thing
yes absolutely i was going to call on
you next
okay thank you um i do
like the 10-year plan um i'm not sure
there's a cost to that obviously and i
and i'm not sure what that cost is i've
never heard a cost
associated with making this 10-year plan
but i'm sure
that's it's not inconsiderable
the other part of this and and i'd hate
to see
a district like allenstown who voted for
this just recently
um at least that's my understanding and
and we're talking about uh the state
portion of their project being 19
million
which uh along with the tail
keeps it under the um or roughly the 50
million that we're
we're currently dealing with um for
building aid
i just want to i and i'm not even sure
if the 19 million is possible in this
current
budget climate but i wanted to
but i wanted to make sure that i at
least put in a plug to say
of all of the 12 projects that are here
from
from my position as the chair of the
school building authority
that one um kicks the boxes um
you know i i'm i'm cognizant that this
year the hall of fame in baseball didn't
include anyone and i understand that
that can happen
but um this is a matrix that um
is needs to be worked on um as far as
retaining the bill that would be a great
piece of it
um as well as all of the other items
that i mentioned the timeline especially
so i would have no problem retaining but
i
um i only have those two issues the cost
of the 10-year plan
and that one project of allenstown that
that is in that 60 category meaning that
um they are they are
a community in need um so they're the
only
they're they're the only 60
project that we have and and they are
the one that went to uh the district
with
a contingency that they would only do
this if building aid existed
which indicates to me that um that
billing aid is important to that
district
so that's my plus i'm i'll drop out
okay thank you very much uh
representative representative murray
thank you very much madam chair um i
support the retain but i have a
i think is a technical question there
was a discussion
i'm looking at line six in the original
bill in line eight and the other bill
it's the same thing
but we talked about this money was moved
to the education trust fund i believe
and in the bill it's referring to the
state operating budget
is that something that we need to change
before we retain or do something with
no we can we can uh
work all of that in the uh retained
category okay thank you
okay um seeing no further
questions or con oh represent cahill you
want to say something
yes thank you very much for indulging me
i'm adam chair
uh again i i did anticipate that because
this is a very complicated issue the
bill would be retained
and hopefully during that period the
revenues will continue to climb and
perhaps the whole will be a little bit
uh less deep but i also wanted to add as
far as the retroactive many of the
schools including new market
also had those kind of issues
overcrowding unsafe conditions firing
life safety
so we checked a lot of boxes we just
didn't get a check
thank you very much thank you
so the motion on the f on the table or
on the floor whatever
is to um retain
hb 594 fn
the motion was made by representative
heath
yes and seconded by representative
petrie so representative lynn
could you please call the role
yes uh thank you madam chair
[Music]
representative petry
future voces
um representative um
well i guess i'm i'm sorry i guess i'm
next and i uh uh i
also vote yes
representative porter yes
hang on one second i just
thank you uh representative heath heath
vote chance and i thank you for the
opportunity to continue to continue this
conversation
thank you uh representative murray
murray votes yes
representative turcotte representative
votes yes
and representative humber representative
hamburger
votes yes all right the vote is uh
two three four seven uh to nothing uh in
favor
short passes okay thank you
um i am not sure when
full finance is going to have their um
executive session on on these but
uh i do thank you all for uh
agreeing to retain this bill i think
there's some
good points in it and um
maybe we can get mary's money tree to
grow
a little bit faster than what we have at
this point
okay so we are now turning
to
let me get my let me get my
stuff together here
to uh hb 6 13.
okay uh representative hill
let's go ahead represent porter i'm
sorry
thank you madam chair this is a real
newbie question
so please forgive my ignorance when
working
up the revenue estimates for this budget
were the proposed
um tax cuts that the governor
asked for included as part of that
revenue
estimate or those in the future so
so they're not included
he correct me if i'm wrong but i believe
they were included in the revenue
estimates
uh that's correct the base revenues
under current law
are stated and then any changes to um
tax rates tax law anything that would
affect revenues are carried on the
surplus statement as a revenue
adjustment so all those changes are
accounted for
okay so can i have a follow-up certainly
so we're working with figures that are
um under the influence of
that any negative influence of covid
and then additionally
reduced by the cuts that are made
to the tax rates so that's why our
numbers are
uh the yeah where they are that's i
think
i think the estimates from the tax cut
did not um reduce
the income the revenue
uh by any uh
significant amount i
i am i think the governor
was uh very uh
he felt very strongly as did the folks
working on the budget
that with the tax cuts uh it would not
affect the revenues and i i don't have
them
just handy right here but so there's
been enough of a rebound then
yes that's thank you okay
okay let's see
on um
turning to 6 13
um representative
hill man of chair okay
did you want to uh talk about this
uh i know you had said
that you um had some
amendments to this but nothing has
gotten to mickey from lost
uh neither neither to me as well um
i had promised i would get it to you as
soon as i received it from ols i've not
seen it but it um it really is not
critical to uh to our discussion today
um it it can certainly be handled
um on on the senate side if it if the
bill gets that far
well except that the last thing i saw
is that you were deleting
uh and again you know all all
references to uh
[Applause]
to the original bill yeah in
the state education special education
state aid which was changing it from
three and a half to two and a half but
uh anyhow
i'll let you if you don't mind i'll let
you
uh talk about um talk about this bill
and i don't mind at all i i appreciate
the opportunity to
um it uh the original bill
uh this really could be two bills um
one part uh which you correctly just
pointed out
um is the special education state aid
it's the first
page first full page and and probably a
third of this
second page um that is a
uh is written to expand the formula of
how many children qualify for at least
some state funding
that was the original bill um
the second part of the bill came in as
an amendment and that was
primarily because the information that
came from um the actuary that the doe
hired
the report and the tool came in in
december and it was
after the time that a separate bill
could be written
so it was merely um amended on to this
bill
so the new amendment that uh we just
talked about the goal was to try to get
rid of the indi
the the original language um for
for expanding the formula of how many
children qualify
that didn't seem to fix the problem that
um
that we're trying to address and uh
and that problem is is something that
school districts
all recognize the problem when high-cost
special ed children move into a district
after the school
district's budget is set
districts worry about this situation and
they put away money into rainy day
capital reserve
accounts uh just last year 117 districts
put away
six million dollars into these types of
accounts
um this part of hb 613
lets districts create municipal risk
pools of the type that are shown in rsa
5b municipal municipal
risk pools are so common that they have
a national association
called a grip for some reason i i'm not
sure what that
acronym means um i spoke with the
executive director to see if any of her
members used
municipal risk pools for special ed
costs
she didn't think any of them did
but she was very excited about the
prospect and promised her
organization support most municipal risk
pools and in fact the three that are
currently operating in new hampshire
are health insurance oriented
risk pools in new hampshire are overseen
by the secretary of state
specifically the director of securities
who i also spoke with
he said that the rsa would need to be
changed
to allow special ed to be an approved
use
this bill does that the director said
the association's
lawyers would draft their own documents
spelling out the parameters of the risk
pool
and that would be the governing document
that he would oversee
he said he would first make sure that
the risk pool followed the parameters of
the existing rsa
the key reason we are enthusiastic about
risk pools in new hampshire is because
of the analysis done by
our actuaries from our own department of
insurance
the analysis showed that even those
school districts
can show wide fluctuations in yearly
costs
the fact it remains that the costs
remain fairly predictable
statewide the actuary from the
department
is on this zoom call to explain more
about this phenomenon
predictability is a good thing if
associations are going to seek third
party insurance coverage
or perhaps they may choose to still
self-insure
we had on the zoom call as well um
who just sent me a note saying she had
to leave for
another meeting um is the uh
vice president of the actuary firm that
was hired by the doe last year to do
further analysis
of our historic historical special ed
data
and build us what we call a special ed
cost
predictor which is something that the
doe now has
in its possession this tool will help
the risk pools accurately determine how
much money
they will need to be paid into member
district
school districts cover their concerns of
unexpected
and unreimbursed special ed costs
it's a very easy tool to use one page of
inputs one page of outputs
and it's all in common use language i've
provided the committee a sample
from the town of payroll which is rick
glad's district
this tool helps immediately because it
would guide districts to suggest
how much of the district how much the
district needs to have in their rainy
day
self-insurance pool as it stands now
districts don't know whether the money
they are putting away in these rainy day
accounts is too much
or too little some districts have
millions in these accounts and one
district has 46 dollars
they have no idea how much they need
this tool works now
but it would need to be updated with the
data the doe already collects
for privacy reasons the doe needs to be
the point person for updating this cost
predictor tool
and i think that gives you a basis for
what house bill 613 can do
i'll be happy to answer questions but um
perhaps the actuary on the line can also
answer any technical questions
his name is chris citarella and i think
i saw him listed in
the participants list
i'm i'm all set okay
uh
dan did you want to testify or did you
have a
okay then i will let uh if you don't
mind
i will let our committee members ask
questions
of uh representative
hill as well as uh
mr citorelli i think he's up someplace
there he is all right great so
representative heath you have a question
yes thank you men of chair i i don't
necessarily have a problem with any of
this
actually um it's an interesting concept
and i think the potential is there
my my concern is that we've not had a
public hearing on this element and
you know just um working with local
school districts
this is an issue that every school
district has
and they may very well be in favor of it
and want it um i
just don't know and i i see that um we
have the
person from the department here but we
don't have any i don't see anybody in
the audience from local school districts
so that's i just wanted to put my
concern that
that this is and it deviates from the
usual practice that we've had
in place for many many years um and um
i just think would be nice to hear from
other
places in terms of of what they
feel about moving in this direction
thank you madam chair
yeah thank you for your question um the
the bill did have a a a hearing in house
education
um it um it
drew pretty much the same comments um in
that uh
this is a new idea i want to
specifically stress that this is
enabling legislation this
merely makes it possible for districts
to
to evaluate on their own band together
create a risk pool draw their own
document
and and have that overseen by the
director of securities and the secretary
of state's office
um it is not anything
um it was brought up that this needs to
be studied more
um we've had two and a half years or so
of studying with uh with the help of the
department of insurance as well as the
outside actuaries that the department of
education hired
we have the report i'm happy to make the
report available to you
it is it is an idea
that is new for this purpose
but it is an old idea for um
the idea of solving problems within
municipalities
um it's really not much different than
what we do with
um with mutual aid for fire districts
currently
um mutual aid is where uh
several districts agree to uh to cover
each other if there is a
uh a fire in a different area this
this is somewhat on that same idea that
districts would ban
together and agree to to help out
and and ensure each other um
on the event that some some unrecognized
event happens after their
their school district has been set in
stone
thank you rep some hill representative
turcotte you have a question
i do good morning representative hill i
don't know if this is for you or maybe
christian later
uh three points that i'd uh ask you to
maybe get back with me
um probably don't need to do it right
here
number one what is the definition
of a special ed student i know it sounds
basic but
i'm pretty new at this stuff
currently in new hampshire how many
special ed students qualify and then my
third
question these are all kind of data
points for me i guess
is say in the last 10 years what has
been the
uh increase in the number of special ed
students in new hampshire that's it
thank you
um i actually think chris would be the
perfect guy
for uh for those uh those questions um
if it's possible that we um
pull him up or is how would you like to
do this man
he's he's up already uh
mickey excuse me just a second did
did we was that part uh the questions
that
uh representative got was that part of
what um doe provided to us
in the in that stack it could be but i
do have rebecca fredette from the
department here who
put that information together to answer
any questions specific to it
if she'd like to respond
okay uh rebecca i'd love for you to
respond if you would
sure so um a definition of a special
education student would be any student
that is
identified under idea um as a student in
need of
special education due to a disability um
as outlined in idea currently we have
um i don't have the exact number right
in front of me unfortunately
i'm working from home and didn't get it
pulled up but it is just over 30
000 in the entire state right now um
if we're looking at just special
education aid and those that meet cap
last year we had 742 students who
applied for special education aid
so that is those are those students that
have those high cost
needs that we're talking about here with
representative hill's
information and um
they met cap at which was set at 59 217
dollars
and there so their costs went above that
amount
and then your next um question was i
think you're the next one was the
numbers
excuse me that was that was at the three
and a half percent is that correct
yes yes
rather than three and a half percent yes
i apologize
it is three and a half times yep i'm
sorry yes it's times
um and then the increase um for this
increase of special ed students over the
past 10 years so in 2010
we had 1 154 students apply for special
education aid
and at that point the cap was um 41
thousand
60 dollars and 84 cents
does that answer your questions
representative turcotte um
pretty much the first one on the
definition do is there someplace that i
can actually look at that or is that
something you can
cut and send to me sure i can i can find
the um
that information for you yes thank you
very much
it might help uh representative turcotte
to know there's 13 different
special ed categories that that students
fit into i see uh representative heath
smiling here i think
she probably had a hand in putting those
together
but um so i feel a little silly asking
at the feet of the master here
um but it is um
each of those um in this cost predictor
tool
um the students are identified um in
which of those categories or multiple
categories that they
that they fall into and and so that cost
predictor
takes that that very private information
and um and puts it into uh this excel
spreadsheet that
that provides the estimated cost
great thank you uh
sorry misters
that's cinderella yeah
i had turned it over on the on the back
so
uh did you have anything you wanted to
add to this
i i i really don't i didn't want to i
don't want to take any time more time i
i think representative hilton
did a fine job explaining i'll just say
that
my role was i'm i'm a property and
casualty actuary at the new hampshire
insurance department
um commissioner edelblut
and representative hill came to me about
what is it now about two
at least two years ago said do you think
this is an
insurable risk and um
and it there is no insurance product out
there right now
that handles this type of situation and
you know you know i'm i'm hesitant to
say that it is
it is a traditional insurable risk from
the property and casualty side and the
idea of a liability
um you know just to make a long story
short
i did an analysis and it does appear as
the representative said it does appear
to be fairly
stable in aggregate
and there appear to be some predictors
as to what
would drive costs for an individual
district
and so it appears as if a risk pool
would work
in this situation um and so i
i did a as i said i did a you know a
high level analysis
and reported the back recommended that
they go to a more
experienced firm that dealt with because
it does have
more tendencies or more characteristics
of a
life or a health product rather than a
property and casualty product and
this tool i've looked at the tool and i
will say it is
it is a good it is a good tool it is a
good um
cost so data that was provided
uh thank you uh rebecca
are you the person that would uh
manage or update this uh data system
so we um greg representative hill would
have to give the correct terminology for
this but we
would um put out an rfp to have this
updated based on our data
each year so it wouldn't be my office
that necessarily does it but we would
reach out again
each year and have the um the data
updated according to our numbers in
special education
okay do we have a cost estimate on that
representative hill because
i didn't see anything in
um the estimate um that was received and
and that was the woman that was on the
line that uh would be the
the person she's the vice president of
the actuary firm in kansas
uh lewis and ellis um is the
is the actuary firm she would be the
logical one to
since they built this cost predictor she
would be the logical one
to to provide future updates
for it she gave me only a verbal
um off the cuff saying you know it would
be
uh less than half of what they paid to
build
the system um and it would also depend
on
what other changes the the associations
of the school districts
wanted to see in in the product um
she would assume she was assuming that
they were building it
based on what they would like but they
had no idea whether it be something that
the districts wouldn't offer
um changes to in in a current year so
she was hesitant to come out with a
fixed price and say here's here's what
it would be
but the um it's set up in the bill that
the doe
would um would do the rfp
um would also um handle the cost
for that for the first five years with
the idea that that would be the setup
time period
um and and then at that point the
associations that had been formed
throughout the state would pick up the
cost of
of that um that updating that
uh they they figured this cost predictor
works
for about three years before the data is
stale
and and needs to be updated so um
that that may or may not be helpful i
i'm hopeful it is
okay uh i've got all that but
we need
as i recall the rfp was roughly uh
a hundred and ten thousand dollars to
build this
so i'm thinking um if we were in the
neighborhood of 50
50 000 um i i can't see we would be much
more than 10 percent up or down on that
okay well i can i can second that
estimate there having been in the uh
prior to my current life
uh my current career i was in the
holding worlds for electrical services
and you know have even half of the
initial costs
i would say is a high estimate
okay so this would be um
50 000 a year is that correct
50 000 whenever they update um
and and it doesn't have to be done on an
annual basis it can be done
whenever the doe determines that the
numbers have significantly changed
so um you know the idea would be that
there would be a three-year contract or
some
something like that with the rfp process
that was what the commissioner had
talked about
um so that every once every three years
the the data would be updated
thank you
son mcguire
honorable dan
thank you very much madam chair um so
again i'm talking on behalf of granite
state taxpayers and i'm only going to
address the the first part of the bill
the main part of the bill not the
pooling thing i don't have anything to
say on that subject
um so the main part of the bill
essentially just
changes the formula by which the state
uh
helps localities with special ed aid
the way that works is uh there's this
cutoff of sixty thousand dollars
um so the first sixty thousand dollars
that
that a cost of a kid is entirely born by
locals um then after that
up to i think it's
i'm not sure maybe a hundred times 10
times yeah
there's about 17 170 000
the state pays what is it seventy
percent sixty percent
eighty twenty it's eighty it's never
eighty twenty but that's the goal okay
okay so the goal is eighty percent of
of the intermediate the amount between
000 and 170 000 and then greater than
000 state pays 100 so um
and and i believe that the total amount
the state has been
putting into this area over time is
is relatively flat so so it's it's not
um it's not unreasonable
to say uh you know due to inflation or
whatever
that that um this this area could be
expanded slightly and what this bill
does is change that 60
000 um number
down to 45 000 or something like that
right so that
so that the place where the state a
kicks in is much lower
um so that's not necessarily
unreasonable but
um one thing that you notice if you
delve into this
in more detail is that uh special ed
spending is not at all uniform
across the state and very in different
municipalities
um if you take uh what manchester spends
on average per student on special ed or
maybe what manchester and nashua spend
as a as a baseline sort of you'll find
that certain communities
and and even large communities spend
much higher numbers than those you know
per
per student in particular uh if you look
at
uh merrimack the town of merrimack which
is about the
third size of manchester but it's
spending in this area or
or what it receives from the state in
this area
is something like two-thirds of what
manchester gets
so you know it's it's twice the rate of
manchester in some sense
and and there are other towns like that
like over
uh possibly salem and others so if you
you actually look at the details
you'll find that that certain towns
are are overly generous in my opinion
um compared to the the standard
of what special ed should be and i think
the reason for that
is that the department of ed has
essentially zero control
or influence over how much
special ed spending is i mean i think
they simply
ask the question how much did you spend
and they
run through the formula and send a check
so
i would think that in this area if you
if you want to change the formula to be
state spends more you could profitably
add a handful of auditors to the
department of ed
who would periodically look at you know
sample
the the special ed spending decisions of
each town
and and perhaps have the power to deny
uh a fraction of their spending
as far as being used in the formula and
and that would pay for itself i think
you could you could spend
you know you could do a certain amount
of auditing
and um and and you would end up
not spending that you know not spending
that much on this on this extra um
benefit so that that's my suggestion
and i i i see some hands raised so i'm
fully prepared to say that i'm wrong
about that
but um but my
my it's definitely the case that some
towns
are spending uh a lot more than others
per pupil and and in to the extent that
it it seems like um if the state wants
to put money in it should require that
towns
make more uniform decisions thank you
madam chair
uh thank you very much uh representative
heath you have your
hand raised oh yes thank you madam chair
i just want to mention
that the cost that a school district
incurs
as a result of special education costs
are driven by the individual students
iep
and i think rebecca can talk to the
specifics of that
but it's not something that is um
whether or not a school district
spends more or less per se but that
it's it's based on the federal
legislation as well as our own state
standards
it's based on the needs that have been
articulated
as a result of the team meetings based
on the needs
documented in the individual students
iep thank you very much madam chair
you're welcome uh rebecca would you like
to comment on that
at all certainly so i can briefly share
with you the process we have for special
education aid in our
office each district that is applying
for special education aid
submits all of their paperwork to us by
um excuse me july 30th
of each year and then we hire
up to six clerks in our office each year
um
to review all of those submissions and
what we do is we
um to make the convoluted process a
little shorter we
look at all of their submissions and
invoices and when we
tie it back to a specific service within
the student's iep
so if they submit to us something for
transportation say
and we look at the iep and it is not
there we would then deny that
claim because it's not tied directly to
a student's iep
but um we pick a number of districts
each year that we do that for and we
review them intensively
um we do a for all of them we don't
review them intensively but we do pick a
certain number of them that we
review intensely each year and that's on
a cyclical basis
so every three years your district would
come up and we would review your
submissions
to ensure that they tied back to each um
each service within an individual
student's
iep and there are times that we do deny
claims um we
if there isn't a documentation that that
service was
within the student's iep we would deny
that claim
um but that is only for students that
are submitted to us we don't do that for
every
district um and every process for every
student it's only for those that are
submitted to us
for special education aid reimbursement
i hope that answers your question
representative berger thank you yes uh
thank you
uh representative porter you had a
question
thank you ma'am sure it's more of a
comment is that all right
i will let you make a short comment
how's that thank you
um just for the record here um i have to
agree with what representative heath
said
about the needs of the children and how
much those needs cost
versus just a general average i know in
our district we have a very loving
family
who has adopted into their families
seven children with severe disabilities
that cost the district a significant
amount of money
um and in that's one what
reason why our costs might be higher
than the neighboring
community that does not have such a
family there
and also one way that we have tried in
hillsborough
to keep our costs down is by offering
our own alternative programs here rather
than
having our students be a scholar you
know
scholarship out to other programs and we
invite other
children to come into our programs in
our town
so that we can save the district money
so there
are things that um schools and school
districts do
that they have no control over and there
are some that they do have control over
but
the amount that a district pays for its
special ed
students is determined by the needs of
the students and not by
having a cadillac program that they're
giving to everybody
our representative honorable
i guess i'll just call you dan it's like
thank you
i'm trying to remember all this thank
you yeah so
the point i was trying to make was not
the level of auditing that was just
described
that okay a bill was submitted and
therefore and and therefore we checked
that that bill matches the iep what i'm
talking about is in more detail than
that
it's the creation of the iep
because i don't think it's necessarily
the case that if you that an identical
student
in one town is going to get the same iep
then and then in another town right the
creation of the iep
is a is a a negotiation process
among multiple individuals and i would
think
and it seems likely to me that that that
negotiation
has would have different out results in
different towns and certain towns
uh would be more expansive or generous
or however you want to say it than than
others
and so if the state is putting money
into this area
i would think it would want to take a
sampling of ieps and say yes
you you know produce this iep reasonably
or no you haven't and have some control
over
thank you are there any more comments or
questions at this point
okay i have uh one comment um
madam chair i just received from ols the
amendment that we had talked about so i
have forwarded that to
you and as well to the entire committee
okay thank you um
i i here's my
thought process on this again um
i think the concept of the
insurance is interesting to explore
okay uh unfortunately
we did not have the amendment as we were
going through what we what we needed
today
and so um
if i could have a motion to retain
that it would give us an opportunity
to um look further
and i i think that um representative
hill has done a lot of work on this
but we don't have the
information i guess that's the right
term that he is
holding in his head and on the papers
so um i would i would appreciate
if uh if we could do that
representative heath are you making the
motion i am madam chair um
it's my pleasure to recommend that we
retain
house bill 613 83 seconds there
thank you
are there any other comments that
someone might have
okay seeing none representative lynn
would you please call the role
yes thank you uh madam chair uh
representative petrie
did you vote yes um uh
representative uh lane i i vote yes um
representative porter order votes yes
heath heath votes yes representative
murray
murray votes yes representative turca
turka chess and representative umber
represent representative hamburger votes
yes
all right so it's a 7-0 vote in the
affirmative
uh madam chair okay
thank you and um we will
once again whenever the executive
session occurs we'll
take that to the full finance committee
um i really thank everybody for
um being here today and
i will say that although i read the bill
uh and i think this is a
extremely interesting concept and
uh i don't know i don't know whether um
anybody any of the communities would uh
take up this uh insurance proposal
but um it certainly is
uh i think a viable option if we
can find if they can find a carrier
because that'll be that'll be the next
thing
that would need to be done so
it is uh 11 50.
we have to be back at one o'clock
and uh please use your um
zoom links for health finance is that
correct
mickey yeah you're going to want to use
your full committee
links not the division 2 links for uh
for this afternoon at 1.
okay so we will see you all at 1 o'clock
and i know that representative petry as
the clerk for the full finance
will have his uh have his hands full
as i said to him yesterday i uh
i was clerk at one time for finance and
uh
these uh public hearings are a challenge
even in the best of times and
i'm not sure this is the best of times
but
anyhow so we'll see you all at one
o'clock and
um then tomorrow morning uh we're back
together
at 10. okay so
have a well have a good afternoon
listening and thank you
to everyone that joined our call today
take care